dernière journée d'audience dans le
procès oussékine verdict attendu dans la
soirée
michel rocard devant ses militants la
défense ils attendent du premier
ministre le rappel à l'ordre des membres
de son gouvernement
complicité de génocide quatre
dignitaires du régime sait où c'est ce
couple est coupable leur procès public
s'est ouvert aujourd'hui à bucarest
l'airbus a321 sera fabriquée en
allemagne inquiétude et mécontentement à
toulouse dominique baudis invités de
cette édition
bonsoir et puis cette nouvelle étape
dans la sphère des clinique marseillaise
jean chouraqui propriétaire de quatre
cliniques privées écroué à la prison des
baumettes sous l'inculpation de
complicité d'assassinât
il s'agit de l'assassinât d'un autre
directeur de clinique léonce moût tu as
battu en mai 1988 le dénouement de la
guerre des cliniques est peut-être
proche de marseille gabriel bruxelles
jojojura qui a pris ce soir le chemin
des gommettes il a été inculpé
jean chouraqui vient d'être inculpé et
placé en détention provisoire pour les
besoins d'information
une confrontation sera organisée dans
les tours bordeaux
nous avons pris connaissance de
l'intégralité des éléments du dossier
nous en concluons tous qu'il s'agit
d'une affaire d'une extrême gravité et
que les intérêts dont nous avons la
charge commande de nous abstenir pour
l'instant de tout moment peuvent depuis
hier après midi cette maison du quartier
saint barnabé était étroitement
surveillé son propriétaire jean
chouraqui frappé d'un mandat d'amener
jean chouraqui qui a dû s'expliquer
aujourd'hui sur son rôle dans la sphère
du meurtre du directeur de la
polyclinique nord léon smoot jean
chouraqui interrogé longuement sur les
accusations portées contre lui par marc
gallet a dit le directeur administratif
de la polyclinique de l'époque au coeur
des débats le différend entre mouté
chouraqui pour cause de rachat
l'établissement les certains qui avait
une rivalité certaine au niveau des
cliniques et notamment de la
polyclinique nord que convoitait
monsieur chouraqui depuis très longtemps
est ce que pour vous tout ça peut
remonter jusqu'à cadeaux je ne sais pas
je ne connais pas monsieur gallo et je
n'en avais jamais entendu parler avant
cette histoire
ce soir jean chouraqui est en prison
pour complicité d'assassinât sur la
personne de leo smoot la faire galoper
chats restent en arrière fond même si le
docteur gallou et jean chouraqui se
connaissent bien
même si jean chouraqui voulait obtenir
un permis de construire dans le secteur
de marseille où le docteur p charité mr
le procureur adjoint l'a répété en
partant peut s'attendre à que tu vois
des rebondissements positif ou négatif
le verdict du procès malik oussékine à
paris verdict attendu dans la soirée
élise lucet sur place les plaidoiries de
la défense sont sur le point de se
terminer à elles sont même terminé éric
et le jury vient tout juste de partir et
de se réunir pour délibérer ils vont
bien sûr j'imagine sortir ou dans
quelques minutes dans plusieurs heures
pour nous donner le verdict en attendant
vous avez sûrement entendu au cours de
l'après-midi le réquisitoire ou en
première partie du 19/20 réquisitoire
modérée pour garcia deux ans de prison
avec sursis
beaucoup moins en revanche poursuite
cinq ans de prison dont trois ferme avec
l'histoire exemplaire pour une dernière
journée d'audience où chacun a bien tenu
son rôle vous allez le voir pour
défendre jean schmitt et christophe
garcia m garraud n'a pas hésité à
dépeindre une situation d' apocalypse
ce soir-là paris viii dans une
atmosphère d'agressivité dans une
de guerre civile il n'y a pas d'ordre
précis ces deux policiers n'ont donc pas
désobéi les jurés écoute attentif et
impressionné sentiment d'émotion en
revanche pour la plaidoirie de maître
tiamat bien sûr il parle des faits mais
si peu il parle surtout du symbole qui
ce soir-là a volé en éclats le symbole
de la démocratie vous souvenez de ce que
disaient les étudiants au lendemain de
la mort de malik oussékine il disait
plus jamais ça que j'avais ça ce soir
cela dépend de vous rien ne serait plus
terrible que la banalisation de ce crime
voilà pour cette dernière journée
d'audience je vous le disais tout à
l'heure nous attendons le verdict dans
la soirée
les verdicts peut-être à 21h50 dans soir
3 en roumanie
c'est le procès de quatre dignitaires du
régime sait où c'est ce coup qui s'est
ouvert aujourd'hui à bucarest les
accusés comparaissent pour complicité de
génocide le procès est publique mais la
population semble beaucoup plus
préoccupé par la situation politique
dans le pays
hélène risacher inc les quatre hommes
clés du régime ceausescu sont accusés de
complicité de génocide et d'avoir fait
tirer sur la foule à bucarest à
timisoara des cautions two door post
miku ans ex-ministre de l'intérieur
patron de la six cordes
manea manescu vice-président du conseil
d'état conseiller de chaouchi school
emil boc
ancien numéro trois du régime l'homme de
confiance de chaouch et secoue et
l'yonne dinka premier vice premier
ministre
l'ouverture de ce premier procès perdu
les dignitaires de l'ancien régime
interrogatoires de l'yonne dinka il se
reconnaît complices ces décisions
ceausescu ceausescu a donné l'ordre de
tirer dans les jambes des manifestants
dit il j'ai donné mon appui à ces
mesures criminelles personnes à discuter
selon la presse roumaine les quatre
inculpés doivent plaider coupable tout
en accusant chevauchée ce coup d'avoir
terrorisé ses proches collaborateurs
jugés par un tribunal militaire les
quatre hommes de chercher ce coup
dispose d'avocat choisi par eux ou
commis d'office
il risque la prison où les travaux
forcés à perpétuité
le 12 janvier dernier la foule avaient
manifesté à bucarest devant le siège du
front de salut national pour rétablir la
peine de mort contre ces terroristes
après des hésitations le nouveau pouvoir
a finalement refusé
de plus en plus contesté le front de
salut national de montrer à travers ce
procès qu'il est décidé à faire justice
contre l'ancien régime et publiquement
l'audience est retransmise par la
télévision le nouveau pouvoir qualifie
ce procès de nuremberg bochum un
droitier de la poterie petit en pologne
le premier secrétaire du parti
communiste sera aussi le dernier le 11e
congrès du poulpe s'est ouvert
aujourd'hui à varsovie par une
succession de coups de théâtre
discréditer le pc polonais annonce sa
dissolution ses principaux responsables
cherchent en fait à sauver l'essentiel
de ce qui peut encore l'être
hubert coudurier il y a officiellement
près de deux millions d'adhérents
mais le chiffre est en fait largement
surestimée compte tenu de la
désaffection massive qui touche le parti
depuis les élections libres de l'été
rendu responsable de l'effondrement du
pays les communistes essaie de sauver
les meubles et le premier secrétaire
rakowski a finalement jugé prudent de ne
pas présenter sa candidature à la tête
du nouveau parti
appelé à succéder aux poupe car la
population supporte de plus en plus mal
que les dirigeants du parti conserve des
responsabilités tant au niveau
gouvernemental que local alors que la
situation évolue plus vite dans les
autres pays de l'est
chaque fois que vois ça fait là encore
les ouvriers avec des polos des unes des
principales questions pourquoi vous avez
rencontré lacoste qui pourquoi vous
voulez aider à garder son poste donc au
vent et ça ramasse tout une toute une
série de critiques d'attac délava le
leader de solidarité voulait pourtant
souligné que le passage au multipartisme
nécessite le maintien d'une force
politique de gauche socialiste ou
social-démocrate son candidat favori
thaddeus fisbach ancien responsable à
gdansk en 1980 et actuel vice-président
du parlement devra toutefois recueillir
l'approbation des orthodoxes encore
majoritaires dans un parti où les
réformistes ont cessé de suivre les
directives du comité central politique
en france michel rocard en ce moment
même devant ses militants au cnit à la
défense daniel sportiello et sur place
dans le contexte politique actuel on
peut le dire les enjeux dépassent le
cadre de la fête
bien sûr
c'est une fête n'est pas une réunion de
politique politicienne
les amis de michel rocard voulaient
éviter de mêler le premier ministre au
règlement de comptes d'avant congrès qui
se coule partie mais michel rocard est
bien obligé aujourd'hui de mettre la
main à la pâte pour calmer le jeu après
les tensions de la semaine après que les
ministres du gouvernement ranger
derrière des chefs de file socialistes
antagonisent se soient mises à tirer les
uns sur les autres et après que pierre
mauroy le premier secrétaire du ps lui
demander à michel rocard d'intervenir
auprès de ses ministres pour qu'ils
aiment leur n'attaque entre le parti au
nom de la solidarité gouvernementale
michel rocard devrait donc exigé
aujourd'hui que cesse la cacophonie au
sein du gouvernement
cacophonie disent les rocardiens qui
risque de saboter le deuxième septennat
de françois mitterrand
toulouse n'a plus le monopole de
l'aéronautique l'a321 le dernier né des
avions airbus sera probablement
assemblée en allemagne fédérale décision
annoncée par le consortium européen
décision qui sera officialisé en
principe le 23 février prochain
satisfaction en rfa déception à toulouse
reportage olivier louvet la version
allongée de l'a320 sera donc selon toute
vraisemblance réalisée en allemagne
une décision qui devrait être confirmée
dans un mois et qui est le résultat de
la réunion du conseil de surveillance
des quatre industriels partenaires du
consortium
ils ont convenu de rationaliser la
fabrication des avions
en clair sur un même site industriel on
retrouvera l'assemblage de l'appareil et
son aménagement commercial intérieur un
principe évitant les va et vient et qui
serait appliqué sur les programmes
futurs
les gros porteurs long courriers a330
340 serait donc à toulouse et les a321
irait hambourg d'ici le 23 février le
conseil exécutif d'airbus réfléchira au
management de ce nouveau fonctionnement
et à son financement
même si l'idée d'un transfert de la
chaîne a320 semble définitivement
abandonné la création d'une chaîne à 321
pour l'allemagne c'est un peu de fierté
retrouvée outre-rhin
mais c'est surtout de la charge de
travail perdues pour toulouse
l'a321 a dépassé les 100 commandes
fermes et compte bien atteint
indre l'objectif des 500 exemplaires
alors dominique baudis et en direct de
toulouse monsieur baudis bonsoir votre
réaction c'est vraiment une mesure
catastrophique non n'exagérons pas
catastrophique mais c'est une mesure
inquiétante pour deux raisons tout
d'abord parce qu'elle fait courir des
risques aux programmes airbus et d'autre
part parce qu'elle est lourde de
conséquences pour l'aéronautique
française des risques pour le programme
airbus
c'est un programme extrêmement complexe
et un avion qui est fabriquée aux quatre
coins de l'europe
le système fonctionne bien depuis
maintenant près de vingt ans c'est une
réussite industrielle techniques
commerciales et je ne comprends pas
pourquoi tout à coup en désorganise ce
système on voit d'ailleurs qu'il est
très fragile il ya une grève en ce
moment en grande bretagne elle est en
train de paralyser la production
donc si on désorganise en profondeur le
système comme cette décision pourrait le
laisser craindre
il y aura peut-être des conséquences
redoutables pour le programme airbus
nous aviez vous avez obtenu l'assurance
de garder en quelque sorte le monopole
de l'aéronautique à toulouse et bouter
les français ne sont pas les meilleurs
dans tous les domaines mais il y a les
domaines où nous sommes les meilleurs et
un domaines dans lesquels nous sommes
les meilleurs nous allons être un pôle
d'excellence en france et notammment à
toulouse c'est celui de l'industrie
aéronautique il ya ici des ouvriers des
techniciens des ingénieurs qui sont de
grands spécialistes des tâches des
métiers qui sont les nôtres dans le
cadre du puzzle airbus et cela nous le
faisons eh bien depuis près de vingt ans
alors monsieur baudis la décision sera
officialisée le 23 février prochain je
le disais tout à l'heure vous avez un
petit espoir de garder la situation en
main à toulouse
quels sont vos recours aujourd'hui mais
c'est pas une affaire qui concerne que
toulouse elle concerne toulouse au
premier chef mais elle concerne
l'ensemble de
l'industrie et du savoir-faire
aéronautique français est ce qu'on peut
redouter c'est que à la demande des
allemands on est en train de tirer une
première my sur le pull-over et puis on
ne sait pas quand on va s'arrêter alors
je crois que là les intérêts nationaux
sont en jeu je ne suis pas partisan vous
savez d'un état touche à tout mais je
crois que lorsque l'intérêt national est
en jeu l'état l'osa vernement appelé le
chef de l'état à intervenir directement
dans cette affaire je pense que dans un
premier temps le premier ministre
devrait réunir une table ronde pour
examiner avec le monde aéronautique
français quelles pourraient être les
conséquences de cette décision si elle
était confirmée
c'est le sens de la seule de ces la
salle démarche pratiquement nous allons
entreprendre aujourd'hui dans l'immédiat
ce que je souhaite c'est pouvoir avoir
une rencontre avec le premier ministre
avec monsieur rocard pour discuter avec
lui les conséquences de cette décision
pour toulouse mais encore une fois pour
l'industrie aéronautique française dans
ce domaine nous sommes les meilleurs
faut-il accepter passivement cette
hémorragie de savoir faire merci
dominique baudis pour ce témoignage en
direct de toulouse d autre télégramme de
l'actualité en france et à l'étranger
commentaires sophie guyot c'est le
manque de carburant qui serait à
l'origine du crash meurtrier survenu
hier à long island
une panne de kérosène duo délais
d'attentes imposé par l'aéroport de new
york où le boeing de fait atterrir
toujours aucune nouvelle du lafayette ce
chalutier du guilvinec n'est pas rentré
au port
les recherches aériennes n'ont pour le
moment rien donné seul l'unique canot de
sauvetage a été retrouvé en fin d'après
midi le bateau était parti en mer il ya
une semaine avec cinq hommes d'équipage
soixantaine de manifestants interpellés
par la police aujourd'hui à paris tenu à
l'appel du mouvement intégriste la voie
de l'islam
le rassemblement avait été interdit par
la préfecture à l'origine il devait
rendre hommage aux victimes azéri mais
les manifestants venaient aussi pour
demander des nouvelles de leurs leaders
à boulouparis gap thani celui ci a
mystérieusement disparu depuis hier
les professions de santé dans la rue cet
après midi dans toute la faune interne
des médecins mais aussi biologistes
pharmaciens ou infirmières ont défilé
côte à côte
tous contestent les décisions
gouvernementales destinées à réduire le
déficit de la sécurité sociale la
solidarité à l'ordre du jour demain ce
sera en effet la journée mondiale des
lépreux
les collectes seront organisées pour
obtenir les fonds nécessaires aux soins
et aux médicaments
actuellement 10 millions de personnes
sont malades de la lèpre dans le monde
les sports maintenant et tout d'abord le
ski y la descente hommes à val d'isère
où les français étaient aussi mon plat
neige super g féminin à santa caterina
ou carole merle est passé tout près de
la victoire
rémy goody szczesny faire médiateur ne
serait sûrement pas celui qui ce qui les
sépare des problèmes là immédiatement
parce que ce n'est pas la douce voix de
rani bullet chili sur le ski est ce que
l'on a
rémy de l'it shelly le point alors ça
marche nous avons donc close qui avait
mis gullit shelly la descente hommes à
val d'isère
donc où les français n'ont pas brillé et
puis le super g féminin à santa caterina
en italie où carole merle je vous le
disais passé tout près du podium ça
marche cette fois non plus on n'a pas le
ski non plus j'aperçois des images de
football
la régie immédiatement qu'est ce que
l'on en voit le football je peux vous
dire que le 8e tour de la coupe de
france n'a pour l'instant provoqué
aucune surprise oui alors sectateurs de
moyenne pour voir évoluer lui histoire
et en championnat régional
ils seront trente fois plus nombreux
pour encourager leurs favoris contre
tous en coupe de france ce match de
l'année pour les locaux daily toutes les
langues
c'est fort que je suis mais enfin je
sais pas ce que je fréquente des gens
qui jouent au foot quoi mais ce but
comme ça en fin de compte
me représenter les blasons aussi bien
d'un côté que de l'autre puisque il faut
garder grand esprit sportif il ya deux
équipes qui se rencontrent il faut
prendre garde et qu'une sakho médiatique
pour les médias les médias sont chez
nous donc pour toi reis que je suppose
pour tous parce que dans la vie
la répétition générale se joue ici dans
le bar qui sert de siège au club dans
une commune de 5000 habitants
il est presque impossible pour les
joueurs tous amateurs d'oublier la
pression certains tentent de faire le
vide et se réfugie dans leur travail
quotidien
c'est pas mal d'être déjà loin de
thouaré ce qu'on a pas toute la pression
des du public autour de nous mais pied
au travail on pense à autre chose c'est
vrai que le football fait du bien on
pense paul travail
je suis au travail je pense pour faible
ian 28 ans a signé sa première licence à
soirée à l'âge de 10 ans il fait figure
de vétéran dans cette équipe de juniors
entraînés par un ancien du fc nantes une
équipe prête à tout pour faire douter
les professionnels tourangeaux at war et
on aime rêver
j'en pense quand même que
les gars de deux tournois gagnés mais
enfin on se défendre on se défendre
voilà c'était le reportage de jean
philippe bien sûr l'avant-match thouaré
équipe de division d'honneur qui sera
opposé demain à 14h30 à l'équipe de
tours division 2 vous verrez d'ailleurs
le résumé demain soir dans le 19 20 je
vous le disais toujours à propos de
football pas de surprise cet après-midi
les favoris ont gagné
et puisque je voulais quand même vous
parlez de ski sachez que c'est siegfried
wolf qui a enlevé le super-g de santa
caterina vous verrez les meilleures
images de ce qui dans soir 3 à 21h50 en
basque est une énorme surprise cet après
midi à la salle de la moutète dans le
brc bien sûr arpèges de l'équipe
d'orthez ici au maillot blanc a infligé
sa première défaite
limoges limoges qui est donc invaincu
depuis le très nombreuses journées de
championnat défaite infligée sur le
score de 115 absent tout autre chose
maintenant le 17e salon de la bande
dessinée de jérôme cathala et en direct
à angoulême jérôme on a beaucoup parlé
bien sûr du sacre de max cabanes d'hier
soir à l'occasion de cette 17e édition
et puis je vois autour de vous beaucoup
de monde c'est donc un énorme succès
populaire qui vient en fait démentir
toutes les rumeurs concernant j'allais
dire la crise dans la bd tout à fait
vous voyez autour de moi l'affluence le
prouve
l'actrice de la bande dessinée ce n'est
pas exactement ce qu'on en dit long il
ya quand même une certaine morosité dans
ce domaine notamment dans le cadre de la
presse de la bande dessinée alors ce
premier salon des années 90 c'est un peu
l'occasion rêvée de faire le point et
puis de jeter un regard critique sur la
bande dessinée patrick ferrante
dominique hervo
les super héros de la bande dessinée
sont fatigués batman le film a même
entraîné dans sa chute sa copie en
carton témoin cette pique d'albums a
vendu dans une librairie d'angoulême
mickey et désabusé n'hésite pas à
proclamer dans le quotidien le monde le
critique bd thierry groensteen mickey ou
plutôt astérix le gaulois
je ne me souviens pas d'avoir lu une
seule bande dessinée française
réellement marquante pour la deuxième
partie des années 80 les enfants d'
astérix ou tintin n'ont pas réussi à se
faire un nom dans les années 80 une
baisse de créativité que livres hebdo a
traduit en chiffres
près de 600 nouveaux titres publiés
chaque année en france mais des ventes
moyennes par album en baisse une vente
totale et un chiffre d'affaires en
stagnation
fatigué le dernier libraire d'angoulême
spécialisée en bd jacques gilbert a dû
se résoudre à transformer sa boutique en
une classique librairie papeterie fondée
garder votre rayon de formation pour nos
membres
vous pourriez l'abandonner ça pourrait
arriver mais gens les achètent de moins
en moins alors à qui la faute
l'instabilité des éditeurs qui se
rachètent qui fusionne qui disparaissent
etc ne crée certainement pas un climat
serein autour d'eux des créateurs très
propice à
la création de grands groupes dont les
noms apparaissent peu sur les albums
concentre désormais les grosses écuries
de tigre de papier dans les années 80
fini lander grande la bande dessinée est
devenu un secteur d'édition comme les
autres la mue achevé reste alliant le
nouveau chapitre la renaissance
peut-être alors justement renaissance ou
second souffle ce qui est sûr c'est que
la bande dessinée doit imaginer de
nouvelles solutions
l'une des ces solutions c'est peut-être
de se tourner vers la publicité et sur
tous les albums publicitaires le
reportage et d'agnès molinier et d'yvon
godin
une histoire qui servent de fil rouge et
qui va se prolonger sur les quatre pages
va les dossiers qu'on va présenter sur
le peuple
quand un dessinateur rencontre un chef
d'entreprise il parle désormais à faire
la bd devient un moyen de faire passer
des messages aux salariés en mettant en
scène des personnages qui leur ressemble
lorsque nous avons introduit la bande
dessinée il ya eu un certain nombre de
réactions
négative ya eu des cris et des
grincements de dents de la part de
certains supérieurs hiérarchiques qui
craignait qu'on tourne en dérision leurs
activités la bande dessinée est une
valeur qui monte
la preuve glina concept filiale de la
maison d'édition après quatre ans
d'existence elle réalise 5 % du chiffre
d'affaires autrement dit la bd commence
à s'imposer comme supports de
communication après avoir fait de la pub
que la pub à utiliser très longtemps
l'image bande dessinée mais pas
tellement le moyen d'expression bande
dessinée nous on se sert du moyen
d'expression de banc d'essai faire
passer les messages plus théorique et
non pas des messages produits mais faire
passer le message d'un client les
créateurs de bandes dessinées la
critique
la plupart oui mais d'un concept
travaille aujourd'hui avec 150
dessinateur la bande dessinée est
l'illustration la possibilité elle
vraiment précis sur un sujet de faire
une image choc qu'un lecteur de la
société dans le cadre da c'était n'a pas
forcément envie de lire
c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas une
demande les lecteurs on lui impose un
dessin dont il le prend et de l'art par
là on peut lui faire passer des messages
différents d'une bande dessinée mais la
bande dessinée peut être enrichissant
pour tout le monde
exemple si lexsi boas après leur
carrière pour l'edf de france
ils viennent d'être éditées pour le
grand public alors jérôme cathala
m'entendais toujours puisque l'on vient
de parler beaucoup de publicité faite me
voir j'allais dire de vos coups de coeur
quels sont les traits marquants de
l'édition 90 du salon est bien le
premier coup de coeur il a été couronné
par l'alph art coup de coeur et bien il
s'agit de couronner deux jeunes auteurs
et une jeune maison d'édition lui voue
s'appelle séjour en afrique qui l'édité
part rackham production et puis je
voudrais aussi saluer l'apparition d'un
nouveau mensuel d'un nouveau magazine de
bande dessinée c'est pas si fréquent qu
sauf si vous savez que pilote et circus
ont disparu cette année ben voilà un
nouveau magazine de bande dessinée il
s'appelle flag bien voilà eric et bien
tout ce que je peux vous proposer de se
retrouver l'année prochaine
ici même angoulême c'est max cabanes qui
fera la fiche de la 18e édition le
rappel des titres de cette édition que
nous développerons d'ailleurs à 21h50
dans soir 3 le verdict attendu dans la
soirée surtout dans le procès malik
oussékine le
l'avocat général a requis deux ans avec
sursis et trois ans d'emprisonnement
pour les deux voltigeurs qui étaient
dans le box des accusés
et puis cette information jean chouraqui
propriétaire de quatre cliniques privées
écroué ce soir à la prison des baumettes
sur l'inculpation de complicité
d'assassinât ceci dans le cadre bien sûr
de la guerre des cliniques à marseille
tout de suite la météo complète de
florence klein je vous retrouve donc à
21h50 soir 3 très bonne soirée à tous